[موسيقى]
اصطحاب الاطفال الى المسجد الحرام غايه
ورغبه عند الكثير من العائلات الا انها
محاطه بهاجس فقدانهم في ظل الاعداد
المليونيه التي تتوافد بشكل يومي لاداء
العمره او الصلاه في شهر رمضان اداره خدمه
الزائر الصغير تستقبل طلاب المدارس في
المسجد الحرام
وتوعيتهم على ما تقدمه الرئاسه من خدمات
جليله مبادره اسواره معصم اليد واطلقنا
عليها طفلك معنا في امان تحتوي على بيانات
ذوي الطفل لا سمح الله في ضياحهم يتم
التواصل معهم وتوصيله في اقرب وقت ممكن
لتفادي الكثير من حالات فقد الاطفال في
المسجد عملت رئاسه شؤون الحرمين على توزيع
اساورات توضع على مهسم الطفل وتحمل
معلومات التواصل مع ذوي فضلا عن برامج
توعويه
وتثقيفيه تقدمها
في رحله امنه للمعتمرين واطفالهم لو حتى ط
فل بيبداوا يتواصلوا معه وبيصل الى ابنه
وده شيء ممتاز جدا وشيء جميل جدا وربنا
يوفقكم وربنا يوفق القائمين على العمل
بصراحه كثير مبادره كويسه يعني
بتقدر ما بتخليك تخاف على اولادك وخلاص
روحوا اسرحوا وين وين ما تبون يعني خدمات
مكثفه تراعي كل الفئات والاعمار في المسجد
الحرام بالتزامن مع موسم عمره استثنائي
واستعدادا لموسم حج هذا العام من الحرم
المكي سلطان السلمي العربيه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات